For some reason for the past week,
I've been craving to go to where I'm from new England,
Connecticut. I'm like, I just want to go back.
I have memories and all these places in new England. And for some reason,
deep down in my soul, I just want to go there.
How did we live here? So cold.
[Inaudible].
Going one way ticket. I'm going to Connecticut.
And then who knows?
So the plan is I'm going to fly to Connecticut.
I'm going to get a rental car.
I'm going to drive to the old neighborhood of where I'm from.
And I grew up and I had some of the best memories ever from there because
that's when I was a little girl and my mind was so creative.
I am flying tomorrow morning and then booking my blank now.
Hello.
My sister just called me.
I'm looking at flights on the planes to see if she can meet me.
[Inaudible].
This is insane that I'm hearing now. So weird.
You go to sleep in one city. You wake up in another,
literally tastes like I'm drinking. A donut, never have sugar like this anymore,
but woo.
[Inaudible].
First off Apple store. And I have to try to fight my hardest,
not to go to my neighborhood, to the karate school,
to anything yet until my sister arrives tomorrow.
I need to find a hotel ASAP because I'm terrified of driving in the South.
I haven't found a place to stay yet.
Probably the best room they have that they're showing the pictures up,
but I'll take it quick change.
I'm actually just going to take a sneak peek at the old neighborhood,
I guess where I am.
Yeah. Okay. You can't see it, but that's my house.
I'm going to have to show you tomorrow.
Looks exactly the same just without all your gardens.
Definitely look really creepy right outside of people's houses. Okay.
I got to move
[inaudible]
I just need it so hard to break it then. God. Ooh.
We're good. Good day.
[inaudible] street. This is our old house.
Crazy. That is crazy. That's
for like 10 years growing up.
Do you mind if we walk around the yard?
[inaudible] you're so sweet. That's so cool.
[inaudible]
it's so crazy. It's so different is from 1906 that you
turned into karate school.
Another thing, right there used to be where the diner was there.
We used to have breakfast
[inaudible].
[Inaudible]
not taking the playground and we're like crazy.
Yeah, yeah.
Everything. Oh
my God. This is crazy. Hi. Sorry.
How are you? What's your name?
Oh my God. Oh, sorry. Amanda. Sony and Samsung. Sony.
Yeah. I'm so happy. We saw you in here. Do you remember doing these
[inaudible]? This is my seat. I sat here and did my wham tests.
I was fastest funny.
So we would run out of quarters to buy lunch.
And Nancy mole night used to always hook us up and make sure
we still ate. And she still does that.
This mirror, this bathroom mirror has been here since I was in school,
but I was like this. We've got to figure out what they need though.
We're going to get them a new playground. Sam.
I started a foundation a while ago and we were creating playgrounds at different
places and it was Cerny. Play the play foundation.
Good teachers, strong, strong motivation for helping the students.
And honestly, they just need more funding East Windsor,
middle school.
Your life solely depends on you.
And every decision that you make in life leads up to where you are.
So if you want to get out there, if you want to get somewhere new,
just get up and do it and commit and make it happen.
It's all in your hands. And nothing is impossible. Oh,
the nostalgia we're headed to Rhode Island and it's only an hour and a half
drive. Live your life, go on an adventure.
Don't forget the small places, small thing. So we made.
It to our hotel room. You got Nate helping us out. And what was the quote date?
That's the fact.
And now massage
first off.
Rhode Island TBD, stay tuned. Make sure you guys comment below,
let us know what you liked about the video and show us some live.
And hopefully you guys get to travel to places you've never been before and just
get up and do it.
I noticed the playground that I used to play on all the time and I
wanted to see if I would be able to help with installing a new
playground into the school.
[Inaudible].